an attack on belgrad Russia on December
30th last year local officials claimed
25 civilians were killed and more than
100 others were wounded in the attack on
Sunday in Russia controlled dones 27
others were reportedly killed and dozens
injured in rocket attacks on a busy
market and shops Russia blamed Ukraine
for both attacks at a un security
council meeting here Russia's foreign
minister accused the west of providing
Ukraine with the weapons it says are
being used to kill civilians the blood
of dozens of killed civilians is on the
conscience of those who arm zalinski and
saying at the same time that the
authorities in keev can themselves
determine what the goals for the strikes
will be before the meeting Ukraine's
ambassador to the UN took the
opportunity to flank himself with
ambassadors from Allied countries in a
sign of unity in the meeting he said the
weapons are being used for self-defense
and against Russian aggression it is
imperative to underscore that Russia's
determination to inflate harm on
Ukrainian civilians has not
diminished on the contrary it has
intensified significantly during the
briefing aded ebo a un official that
deals with disarmament issues stressed
the need to end the use of cluster
Munitions in this conflict by all sides
the United States transferred cluster
Munitions to Ukraine last year and human
rights groups have documented how that
weapon has been used to kill or injure
innocent
civilians Ukraine has received over 100
billion in military aid since the
conflict began 44 billion alone from the
United States nearly 2 years after the
war started still deep disagreements
over which weapons and from what
countries are being used to wage this
War Gabriel loando Al jaaz at the United
Nations in New
York make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer